new video is sparking even more outrage
over the group of migrants accused of
attacking two New York City police
officers that's what you're looking at
on the left hand of your screen those
guys were freed without bail and now
look at this here's one suspect flipping
the bird to the cameras he could care
less another blows kisses as he smiles
and
laughs the other suspect next to him
also putting up the middle fingers and
cursing at those
reporters
remorseless Brazen
smug and now the question is will the
bided Administration Deport these
migrants trace this video is so hard to
watch on top of the video that was so
hard to watch of them attacking police
officers will there ever be
accountability no and for your first
question will the bid Administration
Deport them doesn't matter because if
they do they'll be back in six days how
many cases do we have where these people
just come back it's a revolving door
they go and they come back if you or I
or the Atlanta Falcons as you were
talking about earlier went to Time
Square and we kicked a cop in the head
and we beat up a cop we'd be in Rikers
for the foreseeable future that would be
that there's no bail for us these people
get out get bail it's ridiculous and
it's part of the problem where we cover
the border every single day and we know
there's social media they have learned
that not only are there no consequences
to go the United States they're
incentivized you get free healthcare in
California you get hotel rooms you get
all of the things that the people who
actually are citizens here cannot get
and in some cases are taken out of like
high schools in New York and airports in
Boston and and places in Chicago where
they meet and they gather have now
become these sanctuaries and these
places where they house the migrants and
it's not fair to the American citizens
and they are infuriated in blue cities
across the country from Denver to San
Diego to Boston to New York wondering
why is this happening and now the
president thinks you know because chaos
doesn't pull well he thinks now is the
time to shut the border and I've been
trying to shut it since day one and
those darn Republicans won't they won't
sign on and the truth is come on
everything that Trump did you undid and
that was that was the reason we have
this problem and the cherry on top to
that Kaylee is that messaging from those
illegal migrants that encompasses all of
that it's the message as senator Marco
Rubio put so succinctly it's the message
to the cops that they assaulted it's the
message to the other New Yorkers as they
walk free with no bail it's the message
to all Americans as they go back to the
shelters that we paid for yeah who are
these people I mean look at this guy
this is stomach turning who are you
where did you come from what is your
history because clearly you didn't come
here pursuing the American dream you
came here to flip a bird after beating
up a police officer and according to
Marco Rubio likely going back to a
taxpayer facility now as we think about
the number on the terror watch list who
have crossed our border MS13 who have
crossed our border we don't know who
these guys are we don't know their
specific background but we do know it's
a fact that people of that nature have
crossed our border and what are we going
to do the brilliant idea of sanctuary
state blue jurisdictions let's put him
by the schools that was the plan put
them next to little girls going to class
let's stick people for all we know this
guy was put next to a school we have no
idea and then you move over to Boston
and I saw a stunning report on local CBS
News Boston today a recreation facility
in a low-income Community is going to be
used to house migrants and this
recreation facility is home to a program
a track program free of charge for kids
in low-income communities and the coach
of that track uh program said this we
have kids who are also impacted our
program is one of the few stable times
in their lives but let's yank that
program away from the American without
resources and let's put guys like this
in the recreation facility because
that's what our Founders intended yeah
and I saw the leaders in Boston and
Massachusetts saying well look you all
you all have this wrong these people
came here legally no they didn't no they
didn't and they're basically all out on
parole while they seek Asylum do these
guys look like people who need Asylum
that they are somehow unsafe in their
now maybe they are because they're
criminals right because they do stuff
like this th this picture is worth a
thousand words these pictures are worth
a thousand words that you've got these
people who at taxpayer expense are here
are taking our food our shelter whatever
else and then going ahead and doing this
after beating up a cop can I chime in
here three West coasters yes we've we've
had an illegal immigration problem for
Generations people have coming in we
Southern Californians we know it we
experience it this is new this is not
usually what happens we've experienced
we've had the Border issue for a long
time and one thing we can we've always
said in Los Angeles is you know you you
these were people who were working at M
day jobs they were not begging there was
no excess crime cops weren't being
attacked none of this is normally
accompanying this kind of situation we
have inculcated this with the attitude
that where did they learn you can attack
cops and not have any repercussions
where do you hear this what are you
saying yes who are these people was he a
normal guy they learn social media did
he turn into this jump back in and them
to be this way right and the three of us
from Southern California always used to
go to Mexico to travel to spend a few
weeks or a few days few nights if we did
something if anyone from America tried
this stunt in Mexico you'd never hear
from us again or and any other country
right right yeah H I have the utmost
respect I know we all do for those
police officers day in and day out who
exercise only restraint only
professional REM face of this hey
everyone I'm Emily compano me and my
co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye mcki on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights